you ever think about how important the
oceans are and I daily-life
the oceans cover two-thirds of our
planets they provide half the oxygen we
breathe they moderate our climate and
they provide jobs and medicine and food
including 20% of protein to feed the
entire world population the people used
to think that the oceans were so vast
that they wouldn't be affected by human
activities well today I'm going to tell
you about a serious reality that is
changing our oceans called ocean
acidification or the evil twin of
climate change did you know that the
oceans have absorbed 25% of all of the
carbon dioxide that we have emitted to
the atmosphere now this is just another
great service provided by the oceans
since carbon dioxide is one of the
greenhouse gases that's causing climate
change but as we keep pumping more and
more and more carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere more is dissolving into the
ocean and this is what's changing our
ocean chemistry when carbon dioxide
dissolves in seawater it undergoes a
number of chemical reactions now lucky
for you I don't have time to get into
the details of the chemistry for today
but I'll tell you as more carbon dioxide
enters the ocean the seawater pH goes
down and this basically means there is
an increase in ocean acidity and this
whole process is called ocean
acidification and it's happening
alongside climate change scientists been
monitoring ocean acidification for over
two decades this figure is an important
time series in Hawaii and the top line
shows a steadily increasing
concentration of carbon dioxide or co2
gas in the
theory and this is directly as a result
of human activities the line underneath
shows the increasing concentrations of
carbon dioxide that is dissolved in the
surface of the ocean which you can see
is increasing at the same rate as carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere since
measurements began the line on the
bottom then shows the changing chemistry
as more carbon dioxide enter the ocean
the seawater pH has gone down which
basically means there has been an
increase in ocean acidity now in Island
scientists are also monitoring ocean
acidification scientists at the Marine
Institute and nui galway and we too are
seeing acidification at the same rate as
these main ocean time-series sites
around the world so what's happening
right at our doorstep now I'd like to
give you an example of just how we
collect our data to to monitor a change
in ocean well firstly we collect a lot
of our samples in the middle of winter
so as you can imagine in the North
Atlantic regrette hit with some
seriously stormy conditions so not for
any of you who get a little motion
sickness we are collecting some very
valuable data we lower this instrument
over the side of the ship and there are
sensors that are mounted on the bottom
that can tell us information about the
surrounding water such as temperature or
dissolved oxygen and then we can collect
our seawater samples in these large
bottles so we start at the bottom which
can be over four kilometers deep just
off our continental shelf and we take
samples at regular intervals right up to
the surface we take the seawater back on
the deck and then we can either analyze
them on the ship or back in the
laboratory for the different chemical
parameters the why should we care
how is ocean acidification going to
affect all of us well here are the
worrying facts there has already been an
increase in ocean acidity of 26 percent
since pre-industrial times which is
directly due to human activities unless
we can start slowing down our carbon
dioxide emissions we're expecting an
increase in ocean acidity
of 170 percent by the end of this
century I mean this is was in our
children's lifetime this rate of
acidification is ten times faster than
any acidification in our oceans for over
55 million years so our marine life has
never ever experienced such a fast rate
of change before so we literally could
not know how they're going to cope now
there was a natural acidification of
events millions of years ago which was
much slower than what we're seeing today
and this coincided with a mass
extinction of many marine species so is
that what we're headed for well maybe
studies are showing what some species
are actually doing quite well but many
are showing a negative response one of
the big concerns is ocean acidity
increases the concentration of carbonate
ions in seawater decrease now these ions
are basically the building blocks for
many marine species to make their shells
for example crabs or mussels oyster
another example are corals they also
need these carbonate ions and seawater
to make their coral structure in order
to build coral reefs as ocean acidity
increases and the concentration of
carbonate ions decrease these species
first find it more difficult to make
their shells and at even lower levels
they can actually begin to dissolve this
here is a tarapada it's called a sea
butterfly and it's an important food
source in the ocean for many species
from krill to salmon right up to whales
the shell of the pteropod was placed
into seawater at a pH that we're
expecting by the end of this century
after only 45 days at this very
realistic PA
you can see the shell has almost
completely dissolved so ocean
acidification could affect right up
through the food chain and right onto
our dinner plate I mean could here like
shellfish or salmon or many other fish
species whose food source in the ocean
could be affected these are cold water
corals and did you know we actually have
cooled water cars and Irish waters just
off our continental shelf and they
support rich biodiversity including some
very important fisheries it's projected
that by the end of this century
70% of all known cold water corals in
the entire ocean
will be surrounded by sea water that is
dissolving their coral structure the
last example I have are these healthy
tropical corals they were placed in
seawater at a pH we're expecting by the
year 2100 after six months the Carl has
almost completely dissolved now coral
reefs support 25% of all marine life in
the entire ocean all marine life so you
can see ocean acidification is a global
press I have an 8 month old baby boy
unless we start now to slow this down I
dread to think what our oceans will look
like when he is a grown man we will see
acidification
we have already put too much carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere but we can
slow this down we can prevent the worst
case scenario the only way of doing that
is by reducing our carbon dioxide
emissions this is important for both you
and I for industry for governments we
need to work together slow down global
warming
slow down ocean acidification and help
to may
tane a healthy ocean and a healthy
planet for our generation and for
generations to come
[Applause]